[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه هي العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من
كل زواياه ومن جميع جوابه
على خطه تطليع وشيك لقاء
لاول مره منذ احد عشر عاما
[موسيقى]
لحمايه نظام الحكم ايران تعزز اله القمع
وتدعم الموالينا المقربين وشعبيه النظام
تتقلص للخمس
التوتر بين كوسوفو وصربيا يهدد بتفجر
الازمه بريشتينا تغلق اكبر معبر حدودي مع
بلغراد ودعوات للتهدئه
ولدينا ايضا
تريليونات دولار فقدهما مليارديرات العالم
في 20 22 وائل ماسك على راس القائمه
احد عشر عاما من القطيعه بين سوريا وتركيا
ينهيها اليوم لقاء في موسكو حيث عقدت
مباحثات ثلاثيه بين وزراء دفاع روسيا
وتركيا وسوريا اليوم في موسكو وبحسب
البيان الرسمي تناول اللقاء الازمه
السوريه ومشكلتي اللاجئين والارهاب بحسب
ما اكدته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بعد
الاجتماع اشار الاطراف الى الطبيعه
البناءه للحوار الذي جرى بهذا الشكل مع
ضروره استمراره من اجل زياده استقرار
الوضع في المنطقه كلى سبق هذا الاعلان
تصريحات من اجانب التركي التي تفيد بتقارب
وشيك وبعوده التطبيع مع دمشق اما وزاره
الدفاع التركيه فاعلنت ان وزير الدفاع هو
رئيس المخابرات
وصافي زياره رسميه الى موسكو لاجراء
محادثات مهمه مع نظيرهما الروسيه
كثيره هي المؤشرات اذا على تطبيع وشيك بين
سوريا وتركيا قبل شهر وخلال اسبوع واحد
وجه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
رسالتين سياسيين وبينما اعلن مرتين انه لا
خلاف ابديا في السياسه قائلا ان عقده لقاء
مع نظيره السوري امر ممكن بعد انقطاع
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع دمشق 2011 دعمه
حليفه دوله بهشتري بالقول يجب فتحه لقاء
مع الرئيس السوري وتشكيل اراده مشتركه ضد
المنظمات الارهابيه بالمناسبه هناك خلاف
في تعريف الارهاب بين انقره ودمشق فانقرا
عندما تتحدث عن الارهاب تقصد المسلحين
الاكراد بينما تنظر دمشق لكل من يحمل
السلاح على انه ارهابي اضافه الى الفصائل
التي تدعمها تركيا او من ضمن ذلك الفصائل
التي تدعمها تركيا بالعوده الى الحادي عشر
من اغسطس تحدث وزير الخارج
عن العلاقات مع سوريا مشيرا الى انه التقى
وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل مقداد على هامش
اجتماع الحركه عدم الانحياز الذي عقد في
اكتوبر من العام الماضي في بلغراد كذلك
عقد مسؤول مخابرات البلدين عده اجتماعات
حول امكانيه تطوير العلاقات الثنائيه ثم
جاءت زياره وزير الخارجيه السوريه الى
موسكو يوم الثالث والعشرين من اغسطس لتؤكد
ان تم اتصالات تجرى ودورا روسيا واضحا
للتوفيق بين انقره ودمشق وتحقيق انفراجه
او اختراق بحيث يتم التركيز على نوع من
التعاون المشترك في مواجهه التطورات في
الشمال السوري هذه المؤشرات اظهرت وجود
تغير في موقف انقره من دمشق حيث يتبنى
الموقف التركي الجديد تحسين العلاقات وما
يدفع للتساؤل عن اسباب هذا التغير وعن
توقيته هنا يمكن الاشاره الى وضع بعض
الدوافع والتفسير اولا السياسات المتغيره
للرئيس التركي من طبيعه اردوغان ان يغير
مواقفه بصوره كبيره
اي تحفظات وقد عكست سياسه انقره تجاه بعض
دول الاقليم هذه الطبيعه المتغيره مثل
علاقات مع اسرائيل الانتقال من الخلاف
العالمي الى استلام اوراق اعتماد السفيره
الاسرائيليه امس بالتالي فان اسلوب عمل
اردوغان وتعاطيه مع التطورات يجعلان من
تبدل موقفهم دمشق امرا متوقعا ثانيا ضغوط
الداخل على اردوغان قضيه اللاجئين
السوريين الذين يقترب عددهم من 4 ملايين
وتركز المعارضه التركيه على ان هذه القضيه
من اسباب الازمه الاقتصاديه وان تم فشلا
للرئيس ابن جان في هذا الصدد بالتالي يسعر
دوغان الى اعاده النازحين قبل الانتخابات
المقرره في بلاده عام 2030 حتى يتجنب هذا
الضغط من الاحزاب المعارضه ايضا
ثالثا رغبه الرئيس التركي في التفاهم مع
روسيا اردوغان يحاولوا الاستفاده من الحرب
الاوكرانيه ومصاعد موسكو لتحقيق اكبر قدر
من المكاسب سواء على مستوى الطاقه
والمسائل الاقتصاديه الاخرى ولا شك ان
روسيا تدرك ذلك جيدا وارادت في مقابل
المطالب التركيه تحقيقه مكسب يتعلق بدعم
الحكومه السوريه ومواجهه الارهاب ووقف اي
تقدم عسكري تركي في الشمال السوري
من اسطنبول
اهلا بك معنا استاذ مهند وصحيح ان يعني
الارهاصات بدات من قبل ولكن هذا هو اللقاء
الاول الان لماذا الان وما الذي يبنى عليه
طاهر وجميع المشاهدين بالفعل هي نقله
نوعيه وان كانت منتظره بعد ان اعلن الرئيس
اردوغان بانه فتح وطلب من الجانب الروسي
بان يكون هناك لقاءات مع النظام السوري ذي
مستويات 3 تبدا بوزاره الدفاع ومن ثم
تنتقل الى وزراء الخارجيه ومن ثم الى لقاء
الرؤساء ولكن يبدوا لي ان هذا اللقاء لا
يزال في مجمله ضمن الاطار الامني ولم
يتحول او لم ينتقل الى المسار السياسي
وعليه الامر لا يبدو انه سوف يكون همم
سهلا او
مقبولا او سريعا كما تريده موسكو الامر
دونه معوقات وعقبات كبيره
وليس كما تريده موسكو يبدو ان تركيا هي
المستعجله بالنسبه الى الكثيرين من
المحللين وهنا السؤال لماذا كل هذا
لاستعجال في التغيير الذي يعتبر يعني
تغييرا 360 درجه على اسم هذا البرنامج
نعم تركيا منذ فتره وهي تعيد ترتيب
اوراقها الخارجيه همم بسبب انها مقبله على
انتخابات مفصليه ومحوريه واساسيه المعارضه
لطالما كانت تقول وتعترض على الحكومه
التركيه بان تركيا وجارتها سوريا في خلاف
وهذا سبب ازمه الاقتصاد في الداخل التركي
فضلا عن ازمه اللاجئين همم ولكن هل هذا
وهذه الملفات ملف اللاجئين ملف الارهاب
همم ملف التنسيق السياسي هل هو بهذه
السهوله لا يبدو لان الواقعيه السياسيه
تساعدنا على الكثير من التفاعل في هذا
المسار تريد ان قرا ان تمضي قدما بهذا
المسار مع موسكو لحاجه تركيا الى روسيا
وحاجه روسيا الى تركيا ومن ثم هي رساله
مزدوجه تركيه روسيه الى واشنطن ولكن هل
الارهاب الذي كما تفضلته في المقدمه
البرنامج هناك خلاف على تعريفه تركيا ترى
بان قصده تابعه للبي كي كي الارهابي
وبالتالي هل تنظر دمشق وموسكو بنفس النظر
التركيه هذا اولا ثانيا المعارضه السوريه
بفصائلها العسكريات المستوى السياسي
بالمستوى الشعبي اذا ما كانت دمشق قوى
موسكو تسران على انهم همم ارهابيون مثلهم
مثل هيئه تحرير الشام فهذه مشكله وعقبه
طويله لذلك
او رئاسه التركيه همم لن همم يسلم ايضا في
هذه النقطه كما سلموا من قبل في امور اخرى
همم ذهبوا بدانا في بدايات همم القرن
بالسياسه تصفير المشاكل همم عملت عليها
تركيا لفتره ثم انقلب كل شيء راسا على عقب
حتى تحول الموضوع الى العكس تماما مشاكل
مع الكل مع كل الجيران وغير الجيران وصولا
الى العوده الثانيه الان الى محاوله تصفير
المشاكل راينا ذلك مع اسرائيل اين ذلك مع
دول الخليج راينا ذلك مع سوريا مع مصر
ايضا اذا كانت هناك يعني قضايا مبدئيه
قيميه كانت تعتبرها في هذا الاطار تركيا
في السابق هل تتخلى عن قيامها ومبادئها
الان
اليوم السياسه بشكل عام هي اشبه ما تكون
بنبضات القلب تصعد وتنزل وبالتالي همم ان
نقول بان السياسه متغيره هذه هي طبيعتها
ما كان صالحا في الامس لا يمكن ان يصلح
اليوم وما هو صالح اليوم ربما لا يمكن
صالحا بعد اشهر قليله السياسه متغيره اكثر
من البورصه الاقتصاديه وبناءا عليه بحسب
الواقع الذي يفرض نفسه على الدول تكون
هناك المتغيرات يعني الحرب همم الروسيه
على اوكرانيا فجرت الكثير الملفات وغيرت
الكثير من السياسات الدول اا بدا من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى الشرق
الاوسط الكثير من المتغيرات تحدث وهنا
ايضا يطرح السؤال في ما يتعلق بهذا اللقاء
الثلاثي هل واشنطن سوف تبقى صامته عن هذا
التقارب التركي السوري برعايه روسيه ام
انها بالفعل تريد ان تشغل هذه الدول بهذه
التفاصيل الى ان تطلق همم كلماتها الاخيره
فيما يتعلق بالملف السوري عندما نتحدث عن
عوده اللاجئين المعارضه التركيه نفسها
تعلم تماما وان كانت تسرح على مستوى
التصريحات بانها في خلال عمليه سوف تعيد
اللاجئين السوريين ولكنها تدرك تماما ان
هذا لا يمكن تحقيقهم منذ اسبوع صدر تقرير
عن الامم المتحده يفيد بان عوده اللاجئين
الى سوريا غير امنه ما هي الضمانات التي
سوف تقدمها دمشق لانقر لاعاده اللاجئين
والروسيا سوف تكون ضامنا حقيقيا هذا غير
كافي الامر معقد تفضل على المساله الاراب
الذي تكلمنا فيها اذا همم تركيا تريد ان
تمضي في الطريقه الدبلوماسي سواء على
مستوى داخل التركي وسحب ورقه التواصل مع
نظام السوري همم من قبل المعارضه من جهه
وكذلك التنسيق ما بين تركيا وروسيا في
ملفات متعدده وهنا انا ارى ان لولا ان
الانتخابات التركيه همم قد اقتربت كثيرا
ربما كانت السياسه التركيه الخارجيه كلها
مختلفه اذا هناك احداث تفرض نفسها على
كثير السياسيين وساسه وهذا ليست فقط في
تركيا بل في كثير من الدول العالميه
وبالتالي هنا همم
الخلاف ما بين انقره ودمشق وموسكو عن
تعريف الارهاب عن عوده اللاجئين هل قصد هي
بالفعل ارهابيه بنظر دمشق ام انها جزء من
الشعب السوري طرح كبير ونقاشات كبيره
هذا الموضوع
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه استاذ
مهند اوغلو الكاتب هو المحلل السياسي
تركيا من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس اتحاد شطرنج الايراني
على التوالي وهي لعبت شطرنج الايرانيه
بدون غطاء للراس في بطوله دوليه للشطرنج
في كازاخستان في تحدي القوانين الايرانيه
التي تفرض قواعد صار مع علي زي المراه
اللاعب خادم مولوده في عام 97 معروفه ايضا
باسم ساره سداد خادم الشريعه مصنفه رقم
804 على مستوى العالم وفقا للموقع
الالكتروني للاتحاد الدولي للشطرنج
الاحتجاجات في ايران مستمره منذ قضت
الشابه مهسا اميني في احد مراكز الاعتقال
التابعه لشرطه الاخلاق فسادس عشر من
سبتمبر الماضي يبدو ان النظام يواجه
اسرارا غير مسبوق وتحديا واضحا للتغيير
فكسرت محرمات وركائز للنظام مفعما بغضب
واستياء شعبيين يتابع الشعب الايراني في
ثورته اسهم الوضع الاقتصادي والمتدهور
والتراجع العمله اضافه الى القيود
الاجتماعيه التي يعاني منها السكان البالغ
عددهم 85 مليون منذ عقود في تصاعد وسيره
الاحتجاجات واتساعها التظاهرات ليست جديده
على ايران لكن الحركه الحاليه غير مسبوقه
لجهه مدتها واتساع نطاقها الجغرافي
والطبقات الاجتماعيه والمجموعات الاثنيه
والمطالبه العلنيه بوضع حد للنظام
احرقت صور المرشد علي خامنائي وصور
الخميني وسارت نساء في الشوارع من دون
تغطيه رؤوسهم واطلقت حملات تضامن دوليه
كثيره لدعم النساء بوجه اله قمع النظام
اله القمع عزازتها السلطات باحدى باحكام
اعدام ضد المتظاهرين نفذت منها حكمين هذا
الشهر بينما يواجه اكثر من 80 شخصا اخرين
اتهامات
يعني تعرضهم الاحتمال صدور احكام اعدام
ضدهم اضيفوا الى ذلك ما ذكرتهم منظمه حقوق
الانسان في ايران التي تتخذ من اوسلو مقر
لها ان
476 شخصا على الاقل بينهم 64 تقل اعمارهم
عن 18 عاما قتلوا في جميع انحاء البلاد
بايدي قوى الامن خلال قمعي تظهرك
[موسيقى]
لكن كل ذلك لم يحل دون استمرار الايرانيين
في احتجاجاتهم عدد المعارضين للنظام
يتزايد خلال السنوات الاخيره وفق خبراء
ايرانيين يختصر الباحث في مؤسسه كانغي
للسلام الدولي كريم سجاد بور المشهد بقوله
لصحيفه فورين فارس لم يسبق ان بدا نظام
الايراني في سنواتها الثلاثه والاربعين او
43 اكثر ضعفا من اليوم لكن وخلافا للتحرك
الذي قاده الخميني للاطاحه بالشاه في
سبعينيات القرن الماضي لا يوجد قائد
للحركه الاحتجاجيه الحاليه هناك شخصيات
شخصيات من مناطق مختلفه يشكلون مصدر
الهامل للمحتاجين بين هذه الشخصيات الناشط
في الدفاع عن حريه التعبير حسين دوله
اطلق سراحه في نوفمبر بعد ما اضرب عن
الطعام شهرين والمعارض ماجد توكلي الذي لا
يزاده لا يزال قابعا في السجن والناشطه
المخضرم في الدفاع عن حقوق النساء فاطمه
سبهاريه
[موسيقى]
وان كانت المعارضه بلا قياده فان النظام
الايراني يوجه اله قمعه عبر تنظيمات
وعناصر وقيادات ضد المعارضين في النظام في
ايران يعتمد على الاف المؤيدين المخلصين
لوقت حركه الاحتجاج والكلام لصحيفه
افادت بان الاف من هؤلاء
والمليشيات الاخرى كالبسيج وحزب الله
الايراني لافته الى ان هؤلاء موالينا
حاربوا المتظاهرين في الشوارع بحسب
استطلاعات الراي التي اجرتها مجموعه
التحليل وقياس المواقف في ايران وهي مؤسسه
بحثيه غير ربحيه مقرها هولندا فان واحده
من كل خمسه ايرانيين يؤيدون النظام الحالي
فقط واحد من خمسه
تمكنهم الحكومه غالبا او من تمكنهم هؤلاء
المعروفون المخلصين اذا تمكنهم الحكومه من
خلال الامتيازات الوظائف اسلحه ما يجعلهم
قوه للحفاظ على الوضع الراهن وفقا للصحيفه
الامريكيه
البسيج تبرز كجماعه معارضه للمحتاجين وهي
قوه متطوعه قوامها 700 الف عنصر تشكلت
كامليشيا شبابيه خلال ثوره 79 واصبحت قوه
النسيج شبه العسكريه مؤسسه تتغلغل في
المجتمع الايراني تدافع بشراسه عن جمهوريه
الاسلاميه كنظام سياسي يهيمن عليه المرشد
تدعو الى الحفاظ على قواعد لباس نسائيه
صارمه تدعم التحركات العسكريه الاقليميه
لايران ومن بين المخلصين الاخرين كما
يعرفون الحرس الثوري بالطبع الذي يعد جيشا
قوامه 200 وعشره الاف جندي مكرس لحمايه
الحكومه من الاضطرابات الداخليه اضافه الى
غير ذلك من التهديدات وهي مؤسسه تتبع بشكل
كامل ومباشر لاوامر المرشد عليه اضافه الى
حزب الله الايراني وهي ميليشيا اكثر تطرفا
اسهمت ولا تزال بقمع المحتجين في طول
البلاد وعرض
[موسيقى]
جمعته حقوق الانسان انتقلت ادوات النظام
الايرانيه القمريه
الاخرى لاستخدامها العنف ضد المتظاهرين
شباب من عائلات محافظه للانضمام
مع تدريب على المبادئ الدينيه و وجهه نظر
الحكومه المعاديه
للغربون بالاولويه في افضل الجامعات
الايرانيه ما يضعهم في صف المناصب
الحكوميه العليا والوظائف الاجر الجيد
بالشركات التي تسيطر عليها الفصائل
المتشدده
[موسيقى]
تسعه واشنطن الوقت قدره ايران على انتاج
طائرات بدون طيار تبيعها الى روسيا
لاستخدامها في الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
تفتخر ايران من خلال مقاطع البروباغندا
التي تبثها قنواتها بما تنتجه مصانعها من
سيارات قتاليه ولكن ما كشفته حرب اوكرانيا
هو ان المسيرات ايرانيه الصنع التي
استخدمتها القوات الروسيه لضرب البنى
التحتيه والمناطق المدنيه الاوكرانيه ليست
صناعه ايرانيه خالصه
شظايا المسيارات الايرانيه التي تم
تحليلها في اوكرانيا تحتوي على مكونات
الكترونيه مصنوعه في دول مختلفه ومنها
الولايات المتحده هنا تريد واشنطن لعب دور
فعال في تعطيل صناعه السيارات الايرانيه
من خلال العقوبات على الافراد والشركات
التي تزود طهران بمكونات الكترونيه كشركه
القدسي التابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني
وشركه باربار باريس لتكنولوجيا الطيران
واشنطن في سعيها لايقاف امداد روسيا بهذه
المسيرات الانتحاريه وضعت شريكتي طيران من
ايران متورطتين في نقل المسيرات الى
القوات الروسيه في لائحه العقوبه حتى ان
لم تستطع امريكا ايقاف التصنيع قد تؤدي
الى ارقله عمليه التسليم للمستخدم النهائي
ضوابط التصدير سيكون لها تاثير ولكن علينا
ان نكون واقعيين بشان الجداول الزمنيه لكن
الدول المصممه ستضع يدها على التكنولوجيا
للتطبيقات الدفاعيه المتخصصه او تعدي لا
تصميمات اسلحتها وفقا لما يمكنهم الحصول
عليها حتى لو كانت اقل موثوقيه
والى حين نجاح المجهودات الامريكيه
والغربيه في ايقاف برنامج المسيرات
الايرانيه تعتزم روسيا تزويد ايران
بمكونات عسكريه متطوره مقابل 3
ايرانيه التي استخدمتها في اوكرانيا ما
يسهم في تقويض الامن في الشرق الاوسط
والعالم
انس نماسي العربيه
اهلا بك هل قصرت واشنطن في هذا المجال
تحديدا بموضوع عدم متابعه كيفيه وصول هذه
الجزئيات التي تصنع من خلالها ايران طائره
من دون طياره وتزود بها روسيا في حربها ضد
اوكرانيا
العمليات غير قانونيه
هذا نوع من التحرير هذا ليست تجاره عاديه
او قانونيه همم ولذلك يتم من الاراضي
الامريكيه مباشره همم
اطراف اخرى الى ايران
[موسيقى]
الامريكيه والاخوبات الامريكيه والمراقبه
الرسميه الامريكيه
العاديه
والشديده القويه جدا لذلك هناك
في اوروبا وفي اماكن اخرى في العالم في
اسيا او في افريقيا
شركات او خلايا نائمه يقال شركات مفتاح
على همم بدون رخصه بدون اي مراقبه في
اماكن اخرى في العالم ولذلك
همم
المراقبه عليها معقد جدا وصعب جدا ولكن في
نفس الوقت هناك التشديد المحاولات
الامريكيه الامنيه لايقاف هذا التهريب في
كل الاساليب والمعنى في اساليب السايبر في
السليب العقوبات الاقتصاديه
وحتى في اساليب القضاء بالعنف
الموضوع متعلق بخلايا نائمه في دول يعني
قد لا يكون من السهل او من همم مجدي اصلا
ان تضعف واشنطن عقوبه عليها اليس كذلك
من زمان غير كافيه في همم مواجهات هذه
الخطوره
نعم اتفضل ما المطلوب فعله اذا
المطلوب المطلوب بالاضافه الى الاخوات
الاقتصاديه الهجمات السايبر ضد تلك
الشركات
والربما في
الاتجاه الاخير القضاء بالعنف على السفن
وعلى طائرات او على المفاعيل والمثانه
[موسيقى]
تشترك في هذه العمليات التهريب بالاختصار
هل هل تم التاكد في واشنطن من ان ذلك لا
يحصل من
الدول
تستفيد من علاقاتها بالولايات المتحده
تشتري من الولايات المتحده او تمنحها
الولايات المتحده بعد القطع ولكن تسيطر
فيها احزاب او جماعات تستطيع ان تصل الى
هذه الجزيئات وتصدرها بالتالي الى ايران
والحقيقه انه التفاصيل على المناسبات في
كل مكان
والوادع في مكان واحد يخرف الوضع في مكان
اخر لذلك الصوره مخلوطه ومعقده جدا لكن
على سبيل المثال
العمليات ال همم
عمليات الامنيه الامريكيه المشتركه مع دول
العرب في
الخليج او في البحر الاحمر اااه ضد
التغريب الايراني
انا اعتقد نموذج ناجح الى حد ما نسبيا في
ايقاف على الاقل همم تقرير همم
العمليات التهريب الايرانيه هكذا بنفس
المسيارات والنفس الصواريخ التي ترسل
ايران الان الى مصر من اجل الحرب ضد
اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لك ديفيد بولوكال
مستشار السابق في وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه وكبيرى بحثين في بعض واشنطن
سياسات شرق الادنى تحياتي اليك
في العربيه 360 ايضا بطلوا في نيويورك
تنفض غبار عاصفه القرن ذوبان الجليد يعيد
الحياه الى المدينه جزئيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
حوادث
شرطه خلال احتجاجا واليوم اغلق في سلطات
في كوسوفي اكبر معبرين حدودي مع صربيا بين
البلدين اتى هذا بعد ما اقامه محتجون
الصلب في مدينه ميتروبيتشال منقسمه عراقيه
في شمال جديده على الطرق
نحو خمسين الف صربيه يعيشون في الاجزاء
الشماليه من كوسوفو ذات الاغلبيه
الالبانيه ويرفضون الاعتراف بدوله كوسوفو
او بحكومتها ينظرون الى بلغراد على انها
عاصمه لهم وتدعمهم في ذلك الصربيا التي
اعلنت قصب واستقلالها عنها عام 2008 وقد
دعى كل من الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو الى
ضبط النفس وقالت قوه حفظ السلام في بيان
نحث جميع الاطراف على مساعدتنا على بسط
الامن وضمان حريه الحركه
ومنع روايات المضلله من التاثير في عمليات
الحوار
[موسيقى]
في تونس تعتزم سلطته تخفيض في دعم المواد
الاساسيه بنسبه انت تجوز 30 بالمئه
والمحروقات بنسبه تفوقه 25%
العام 20 23 في خطوه لمواجهه عجز ميزانيه
الدوله والضغط على النفقات العموميه
اجراءات اشتكى منها المواطن وتؤكد منظمه
المجتمع المدنيه انها ستكون بمثابه حرب
على الفقراء وقد تؤدي الى انفجارات
اجتماعيه
يعملوا فوزي في احدى احياء العاصمه
التونسيه في مجال المطاعم وتقديم الاكلات
السريعه منذ ازيد من 30 عاما يقول ان سنه
الحاليه هي الاصعب بنسبه اليها في ظل
الارتفاع الجنوبي للاسعار المواد الاوليه
والاستهلاكيه
اصحاب المهن الصغرى من ارتفاع الاسعار
يتقاسمه معهم المواطن الذي وجد نفسه مضطرا
الى الله وراء مواد الطاقه والوقوف في
توابير من اجل تحصيل بعض المواد الغذائيه
المفقوده من المحلات والاسواق
المعزه فيه الضوء انا ماشيين في التصعيد
مش يزيدوا فيه شلون يخللونه
تحط 30 دينار وتروح وما في مشكله
قانون الماليه
[موسيقى]
الاساسيه بنسبه تفوق الثلث وسيشهد دعم
المحروقات تراجعا بالنسبه تفوق الربح
رفضته منظمات المجتمع المدنيه وبررته
الحكومه بالظرفيه الاقتصاديه الصعبه محليا
والوليا
هناك ارتفاع متواصل في كل المواد وفي كل
الخدمات وخاصه بارتفاع عملها ثمن
المحروقات اكيد منها بقيه
المكونات
ترفع منها ترفع في الكلفه وبالتالي هذا
يازم الوضع لشرائح كثيره من المجتمع كنا
نخشى عن الشرائح الضعيفه اليوم حتى شرائح
المتوسطه اصبحت بتبيعه العين مهدده كذلك
وتعمل تونس على تحقيق نسبه نمو في حدود
واحد فاصل ثمانيه بالمئه سنه القادمه عبر
تفعيلي عدد من الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
والحصول على قرض مالي جديد من صندوق النقد
الدوليليا
بين نظرتي مواد الطاقه والمواد
الاستهلاكيه وغلاء اسعارها وشح الموارد
الماليه للدوله تتواصلوا معاناه التونسيين
الذين تراجعات قدرتهم شراءيه وسطها
تحضيرات من توتر الوضع الاجتماعي وليد عبد
الله العربيه
تونس
[موسيقى]
من الحرب في اوكرانيا الى الحرائق في
اسبانيا والبرتغال وصولا الى ازمه تايوان
واخيرا كاس العالم في قطر تميزت العربيه
بتغطيات جابت فيها العالم لتنقل لكم الخبر
من مكان حدوثه في التقرير الاتي نستعرض
واياكم جانبا من تغطيات زميلنا لايت
بازاري قبل ان نتابع معه
نحن هنا في درب اللستيل كما تشاهدون في
عمق الصوره الحافله التي تحمل لاعبي
المنتخب الارجنتيني هاي الاجواء هنا وهناك
شكرا لك نسرين
[موسيقى]
من مناطق الغابات والبلدات المنكوبه
والمحظوره ليتزاري العربيه اسبانيا
من الحدود
الاوكرانيه عن الرومانيه هنا رومانيا
[موسيقى]
انا الان علمتني هذه الباخره العملاقه
التي ستعبر بحر البلطيق متجهه من هنا من
السويد الى فنلندا
[موسيقى]
يحمل الكثير من الفنلنديين تاشيرات عبور
روسيه ما يمنحهم فرصه دخول الاراضي
الروسيه نحن هنا في صفوف غابات تبرع
التابعه لاقليم تمر الاسباني نحن هنا جنوب
جزيره تايوان في منطقه
[موسيقى]
ومعنى هنا في الاستوديو الزميل لايف
بازيري ليطلعنا على الكثير من التفاصيل كل
عام وانت بخير عيد ميلادك اليوم
شكرا لك شكرا
العاطف عندما شاهدت هذه السيده على الحدود
الاوكرانيه الرومانيه وهي تحمل مفتاح
بيتها بالقضيه الفلسطينيه تحديدا عندما
غادر الفلسطينيون اراد 48 وكانوا يحملون
المفتاح بيوتهم العوده يوم مع ولكن هذه
السيده قالت لي سنعود نحن هنا في بولندا
او في رومانيا تحديدا ببدعه ايام وسنعود
الى بيتنا قريبا ولكن عليه ان اترك البلد
من خار كيف تحديدا لاكون هنا وهذا مؤثر
جدا علينا خاصه
باسبانيا والبرتغال موضوع الحرائق ايضا
لانه عم نرجع نشوف الصور لاهم هذه
التغطيات شو اللي ابرز ما تذكر من هذه
التغطيات حجم الخطوره التي كانت عليكم
النقطه الاقرب التي استطعتم الوصول اليها
نعم هذه العواصف الرمليه الرماديه الى صح
التعبير ولكن الاهم من ذلك طاهر اليوم
الذي يحدث في اسبانيا نعرف جميعا ما يحدث
في اسبانيا من تصحر ولذلك ان نعيد مشاهده
تلك الاشجار التي لم تحترق او لم يحترق
البعض منها سوف يحتاج الامر الى 12 عاما
وهذا ليس اكيد ان ترجع ان تنمو هذه
الاشجار مره اخرى مع التغير المناخي هذا
هناك الكارثه اكثر من من شاهدنا طبعا في
هذه القريه التي تقع في ثمار وكان طبعا
قوات الدفاع المدني يقومون باخلاء بعض
المسنين الذين رفضوا تركب بيوتهم للحفاظ
على منازلهم ممتلكاتهم ولا ولا يخشون اسنت
النار طيب ان ننتقل الان الى فنلندا همم
يعني ليست منطقه حرب المعنى الكامل الكلمه
ولكن على مشارف منطقه حرب ونحن نشاهد
الصور الخاصه بفنندا في تغطياتك حدثنا عن
جزئيه القرار كيف تتخذ قرارا همم
الى اي حد ستدخل في منطقه معينه الى اي
حدث الى اي حدث ستخاطر بنفسك بالفريق الذي
معك كيف يتم التعاون مع همم اداره همم
العربيه في ما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع مع هيئه
البرامج او التحرير نعم عاده عند عندما
نذهب الى منطقه محظوره بين قوسين نحاول
دائما الاقتراب بحذر وعلينا دائما ان
نحافظ كما تفضل قبل قليل همم على خصوصيه
المنطقه العسكريه اذا صحت تعبير ولكن كانت
الصدفه او شاءت الصدفه ان نذهب الى منطقه
الحدود الروسيه الف عندما ركبت على متن
باخره من ستوكهولم الى هلسنكي وعاده هذه
هذا الخط ال- ال- البحري يحمل خصوصا صيفا
عندما صورنا هذا التقرير او هذه التغطيه
يحمل عاده روس يتواجهون الى اوروبا لقضاء
الاجازه الصيفيه ولكن مع اغلاق الحدود
شاهدنا الكثير منهم يتجهون عكسا من روسيا
الى فنلندا ومن ثم من هذه السنكي الى
ستوكولن
للخروج من روسيا
والهرب كمان هذه الحدود روسيون او روس
يتركون على المنطقه المتجهين الى اوروبا
الغربيه
الان وهي كانت ايضا محطه انذار العالم في
20 22 خاصه
لجهه الخشيه العالميه من اقدام الصين في
تايوان على ما اقدمت عليه روسيا في
اوكرانيا نعم صحيح وهذه الصور تشهد على
ذلك كيف كانت التدريبات التايوانيه طاهر
في هذه المنطقه والادها من ذلك عندما
وصلنا الى مصانع
السمكونداكتورز او اشباه الموصلات لم
اتوقع يوما من الايام ان تقوم حرب في
العالم وهذا صحيح حول شرائح الكترونيه
وهذا ما يحصل تحديدا في تايوان والكثير من
التايوانيون يريدون يعني مش الكثير البعض
منهم يقدم ولائه للصين ويامل ان تكون تلك
المصانع او المصانع اشباه الموصلات في
الصين وهناك طبعا شاهدنا الانتخابات التي
حدثت في الخامس والعشرين من نوفمبر في
تايوان والكثير صوتوا للصين
جزء منها اكثر كاس العالم
قليل نراها الان اعتقد يعني اكثر همم
للوطن العربي وللشعب العربي المواطن
العربي اذكر تماما هذا الشخص السوداني
الذي بكى على الهواء طاهر عندما همم
شاهدني في مداخله وقال لي نحن فرحون عندما
فازت المغرب على احد المنتخبات في كاس
العالم وطبعا لا انسى الشاب الاردني عندما
قال لي بلاد العرب اوطاني من الشامي
لبغداد ومن نجد الى يمن الى مصر فتطواني
هذه كان من 360 اذكر تماما واخر المداخله
عند قم بدي اسلم منها ولا راويه وقام طبعا
بالاقتراب من الميكروفون وقام
بقول ما هذا النشيد العربي الشهير ليث همم
يعني انت كنت بتعمل كثير تقارير سياحه في
العالم
انتقلت بعدها الى الكثير من المناطق
الخطيره والمناطق اللي فيها تحديات واللي
فيها حروب ما بعرف يعني حسدوك الناس على
ما كنت تقوم به مع انه انت كتبت لي انه
صعب جدا يعني حتى لو كان في اطار السياحه
والاكل وغيره عن طاهر فينا نقول مش 360
درجه 180 درجه تغيرت حياتي
لا يوجد هناك
ذلك طبعا توجهنا الى هذه المغامره التي
بدات مع كورونا في يوكوهاما دانو برنسس او
باخره الباخره المبوءه انا اذكر تماما في
شباط عام 2020
واصعب تغطيه او الاكثرها يعني همم
باعتقد التجربه الحدود الاوكرانيه كانت
حدود اوك نعم ابدا ولكن انجحها هي التجربه
يعني فرحا وايجابيا ان يكون هناك في بلد
عربي
ومنتخبات عربيه تصل الى مراتب لا تصل لها
من قبل شو يعني لك انك تكون بالستوديو بعد
كل هاللف والدوران في العالم
هدوء ههه
كويس شكرا يعني ما بعرف اذا عم تهجينا ولا
عم تمحنا ولكن اشكرك جزيلا ههه
يعني مو فاضي العربيه المتنقل المتجول في
العالم شو المخططات 20 23 ان شاء الله لحد
هلا عيد ميلادنا اليوم راح نشوف الايام
المقبله اكيد بترتاح يعطيك الف عافيه شكرا
هنا في درب اللستيل كما تشاهدون في عمق
الصوره الحافله التي تحمل لاعبي المنتخب
الارجنتيني هاي الاجواء هنا وهناك شكرا لك
نسرين
[موسيقى]
من مناطق الغابات والبلدات المنكوبه
والمحظوره ليتزاري العربيه اسبانيا
من الحدود
اذا احصيت سبع وخمسون وفاه
[موسيقى]
نعود اليكم بعد هذا الفاصل القصير فارجو
ان تتفضلوا بالمقائم معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نظره التشاؤميه للاقتصاد
العالمي حملتها صدمات العام 20 22 سلسه
ازمات ناقضت التوقعات السابقه بان 20 22
سيكون عاما من الازدهار الارتفاع الحاد في
الاسعار زياده معدلات الفائده الاحترار
المناخي ازمه الطاقه الخانقه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا كلها ازمات تنظر
بعام قاتم في 20 23 المؤرخ ادمنتوس اطلق
على 20 22 تعبيرا يلخص ما حدث نحن نتحدث
عن عنوانه هو عام متعدد الازمات متحدثا عن
صدمات متباينه تتفاعل معا لتجعل الوضع
العام في غايه الصعوبه صدمات بدات وتزايدت
منذ بدايه القرن مع الازمه الماليه عام
2008 ازمه الديون السياديه
ازمه الطاقه لم يشهد همم وضع بهذا القدر
من التع ده ماندو الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وفقا خبراء مشهد اكده بنا رئيس قسم تحليل
الاقتصاد الكلي في اوكسفورد ايكونوميكس في
مقابله مع العربيه اوضح فيها اسباب النظره
تشاميا للاقتصاد العالمي
نتاباتهم توقعاتنا في اكسفورد اسوا من
الاراء السائده بشان نمو الاقتصاد العالمي
السنه القادمه نحن نتوقع ضعفا اكبر وركودا
اسود من توقعات الاخرين لكن اذا نظرنا الى
التجارب التاريخيه هذا الركود سيكون
محدودا وسيكون اصغر من متوسط الفترات
السابقه في التاريخ
[موسيقى]
او حتى المستقر الا ان الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا والارتفاع الحد في اسعار الطاقه
بدل الوضع سجل التضخم مستويات غير مسبوقه
منذ سبعينيات والثمانينات دافعا ملايين
العائلات في الدول الناميه الى الفقر
ومهددا للاسر في الدول الفقيره بمزيد من
البؤس غير انه بدا يتباطئ او بدا يتباطئ
الى 10% في منطقه اليورو في نوفمبر وسته
بالمائه في الولايات المتحده في اكتوبر
ويمكن ان يتراجع التضخم في الدول المتطوره
والناشئه الكبرى من مجموعه العشرين في
20/3 23
24 بحسب منظمه التعاون والتنميه في
الميدان الاقتصادي الا ان الرئيس قسم
التحليل الاقتصاد الكلي في اوكسفورد
كانوميكس لديه راي اخر
واو ويلي اكس خليط من العوامل وراء الركود
منها التضخم العالي الذي يضغط على استهلاك
الاسر والدخل الحقيقي ويؤدي الى تقليل
الانفاق اضافه الى سياسات تجديد الفائده
التي شاهدناها على مدار السنه وهذا يحتاج
وقتا ليتجسد في الاقتصاد بشكل حقيقي
[موسيقى]
اذا هذه الصعوبات عمد حكام المصارف
المركزيه المكلفين بشكل اساسي اذا عمد
الحكام المكلفون بشكل اساسي بالحفاظ على
استقرار الاسعار الى معاوده زياده معادلات
الفائده وهو امر حذر من انه سيتواصل في 20
23 غير ان هذه الاستراتيجيه الضغط على
الاقتصاد من خلال زياده كلفه الاقتراض على
الاسرار والشركات ما يفاقم المخاوف من
الركود الامر نفسه ينطبق على الدول التي
ازدادت مدينتها بعد الازمه الماليه
والازمه الصحيه وفي دليل على الاجواء
الاقتصاديه القادمه يتجه
2008 الماليه
لكن العالم ما زال بعيدا عن الركود المعمم
في 20 23 مع توقع نمو بنسبه 2.2% وفقه
منظمه الامن والتعاون في الميدان
الاقتصادي واثنين فاصل سبعه بالمئه صندوق
النقد الدولي الذي توقع في الاسابيع
الاخيره ان تكون فرص تسجيل اثنين بالمئه
فقط ازدادت لكن المملكه المتحده دخلت في
ركود ويعتقد من قبل الكثير من خبراء
الاقتصاد ان المانيا وايطاليا ستتبعان
فيما اضاف بنا رئيس وتقسم تحليل الاقتصاد
الكلي في اكسفورد ايكونوميكس ان الولايات
المتحده الى القائمه ستضاف
وذلك خلال مقابل
[موسيقى]
اداء الولايات المتحده قد يكون افضل نسبيا
على المدى القريب وبشكل عام نتوقع ان تكون
الاقتصادات الناشئه افضل الاقتصادات
اذن وزاره الدفاع السوريه تصف اللقاء
الثلاثي الروسي التركي في موسكو لوزراء
الدفاع في هذه الدول بالايجابي فقد
الملياردورات حول العالم ما يقرب من
يونايت دولار نتحدث عن 2000 مليار دولار
في عام 20 22 وفقا لمجلات فورس خسر اصحاب
المليارات في الولايات المتحده 660 مليار
دولار وهي تعادل ثلث القيمه الاجماليه
العالميه وهو اعلى معدل في اي بلد وفقا
لاحصاءات فورس حيث انخفضت اسعار اسهم
شركات التكنولوجيا بسبب ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده وارتفاع معدلات التضخم وتدهور
الاقتصاد اليوم انخفض سهم كسلا بواقع احد
10% وهو همم ما اسهم باغلاق السهم على
تراجع فقد تراجعت اسهم تسلى بنسبه 73% عن
اعلى مستوى لها في نوفمبر 20 21 في منخفض
السهم بنسبه
69% في عام 20 92 صحيفه وست ستريت جورنال
ذكرت ان تسلا ستستمر في وقف الانتاج لمده
اسبوع في منشاتها في شنغهاي لمواجهه صعود
جديد من اصابات كورونا داخل قوتها العامله
الصينيه وهو ما يفسر هذا
التراجع الان هناك بعض من الارتفاع نتحدث
عن عن اثنين فاصل سبعه بالمئه تقريبا
[موسيقى]
شكرا لمحمد صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من
مدينه اوكرا من مدينه اوكرانيه حيث دبابه
روسيه مدمره عليها رسومات اوكرانيه على
جانب الطريق وكانها اشاره للعابرين بان
الحرب مرت من هنا
ومن مدينه
بشرق الصين حيث تسبب الضباب الكفيف الذي
حجب الرؤيه في حادث سير فوق جسر تمثل في
اصطدام اكثر من 200 سياره
نرد الامانه الان لعاد العيدان بعدما
سلمنا لي 360 وسلمه ونحن بدورنا لاخبار
الساعه معنا الليله اهلا عادل مجددا اهلا
بك طاهر بالتاكيد لدينا ملفات عديده اهمها
لاسم الصامته بين ايران وسوريا وكذلك ايضا
الولايات المتحده ماذا ستفعل في قضيه
المسيارات وغيرها مع تفضل شكرا جزيلا